the agenda is said hello everyone I'm
Brent Goff in Berlin today on the show a
king for a change the Dutch and their
monarch how something very old suddenly
feels very modern that in more today
it's time to talk also on the show
chemical weapons in Syria US President
Obama for the first time saying chemical
weapons may have been used there today
we ask what does the US and the world do
now in Bangladesh they make many of the
clothes that we buy at rock bottom
prices but some of those texture workers
lose their lives trying to make a living
hundreds of workers died when this
garment factory collapsed last week who
should be held responsible and how many
people have to die in order to ensure
that this huge industry is no longer a
death trap and in party mode awash in a
sea of orange the Netherlands is
celebrating a new man on the throne a
prince becomes king willem-alexander
takes the scepter of power from his
mother Queen Beatrix a sovereign
transition at the stroke of a pen and a
nation in love with its Royals well I've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest says that his people love the
monarchy so much that the thought of
having a president will sends them
running for the crown I'm happy to
welcome to the show your dice whoa go he
is a Dutch journalist on assignment here
in Berlin that's quite a statement to
make mr. ice Vogel you're busy
explaining the love of for the Royals
here in Germany explaining that what's
going on in your own country how is it
that the Netherlands can be so modern
can be so open and at the same time be
in love with royalty it's probably
because so many chain things are
changing already in this day and age
that this one symbol of continuity and
Duchess is cherished okay well we're
going to talk about cherishing that in
just a moment glad to have you on the
show my second guest has played a
significant role in showing the world
the ugly face of bangladesh's garment
industry i'm happy to welcome to the
show today anon my eat he is a
Bangladeshi British filmmaker he's done
several film he's got a new one coming
out on Bangladesh and we're going to
talk about in just a moment but none
this is an industry where people are
forced to work when they know that all
of the walls around them are about to
collapse at any time basically who is
responsible here I would say the factory
owners factory owners are one of the
biggest culprits I'd say the government
needs to take responsibility and also
the brunz I primack zara any of these
mango they need to take responsibility
is well they can't think that you know
we're just going to put in an order and
then you know walk away from it and
think that if anything happens in those
buildings that was not our
responsibility okay I would say those
are the things that I'd like to talk all
right we're gonna we're going to talk
about culpability in just a moment glad
to have you on the show and my next
guest says we should check our colors
when we talk about a red line being
crossed in the Syrian civil war I'm
happy to welcome to the show Marcus
crime he is from the German Institute
for International and security affairs
he's one of Europe's leading geo
political analysts mr. came despite the
report of possible chemical weapons
being used in Syria it really doesn't
feel like the US or the international
community are any closer to taking
action in Syria why is that I think for
two reasons first we still do not have
really credible evidence credible proof
of what had what has happened in aleppo
and damascus on on mar 19th actually we
would need soil we would need blood
samples and other things which are
simply not available because we do not
have an un you
and delegation on the ground in Syria
and the second thing is I think what is
described by the US as a healthy
skepticism towards the events in in
Syria oakley is an effort to avoid any
international election all right yeah a
healthy skepticism that's an interesting
way to put it in the Syrian crisis no
one wants to be accused of making the
same Iraq mistakes and that means
intelligence has to be reliable and that
means telling people the truth now that
seems so simple yet it is incredibly
difficult to do Damascus is not inviting
inspectors to look up its weapons skirt
the White House as it pains right now
not to sound any alarms and so far we
know that the US has reason to believe
the Assad regime has probably used
chemical weapons on Syrian soil the
language is so cautious that it leaves
us basically where we have been all
along on the course of watch and see so
the question is is that about to change
obviously horrific President Barack
Obama called it the red line for us
intervention now that line appears to
have been crossed as the conflict in
Syria drags on evidence is mounting that
the regime has used the deadly nerve
agent sarin against rebel fighters
although US defense secretary Chuck
Hagel admitted there was some
uncertainty that the US intelligence
community assesses with some degree a
varying confidence at the Syrian regime
has used chemical weapons on a small
scale in Syria according to US
intelligence the Syrian military has
likely used sarin on at least two
occasions in the Civil War Senator John
McCain says the president must now stick
by his vow to take action president in
recent the situation in Syria is
unacceptable the president United States
said that this would be a red line if
they use chemical weapons the president
united states has now told us that they
used chemical weapons
as the country's civil war rages the
question of military intervention by the
West now seems more acute than ever we
see right there mr. Kimes that even when
you talk about chemical weapons in
Washington it becomes very political are
we any closer though to seeing
Washington move in terms of acting in
Syria I mean the crucial question is
what does it mean the use of chemical of
chemical weapons in Syria with two minor
incidents a small scale it did not kill
so many civilians as a usual chemical
weapons attack as we have seen it in the
past so all the question is is really
the red line a red line and has it been
crossed and again I think all reports
the first one came in by the Israeli
government than but British and the
French government's all have been very
careful and very reluctant to draw any
operational military conclusions from
that and what's interesting is the world
is talking not so much about the use of
chemical weapons right now more so about
this red line that Obama mentioned has
he put painted himself into a box by
listing this as a criteria for basically
taking military action I think he has
created a maybe a trap for himself on
the 10 years is facing a dilemma on the
one hand there's an growing inward
looking mode in the US politics nobody
has an interest to get involved in any
military engagement in the Middle East
by aerial strikes or buying boots on the
ground but on the other on the other end
years he has committed it's him self
personally with mentioning the red lines
that the US one day would be engaged
militarily leading the international
community so it has become a question of
personal credibility for him and a mid
and long-term perspective the same case
could be applied to Iran
after he has announced president obama
that that crossing a red line would also
mean that the if Iran would go nuclear
in the foreseeable future that would be
also crossing a red line but this use of
the red line is actually he's giving
something to the rebels in Syria isn't
he because once he said that the rebels
then had as a goal to prove that
chemical weapons have been used so he's
almost forcing this issue by saying that
is a red line maybe not forcing but I
think you're right he has given some
leverage to other so it's not only a
question of a decision by the US but
also leverage of others and I think it's
pretty obvious that the US is preparing
for some some incidents maybe not
tomorrow but in the in the next weeks or
month to come in the context of the
final fall of the Assad regime and what
about them preparing mr. Khan because we
know that the Pentagon has sent in
troops into Jordan for example and and
these troops they're not ground troops
there what they referred to as
headquarter troops but it's important to
note that if these troops are in an area
they basically paved the way for any
type of military intervention that could
come I mean that's a significant move by
the Pentagon absolutely it's it's a it's
a command track to prepare a bigger
military operation and it should say I
think it's at least currently its
intended to send different political
signals and political signals to the
international community to as to public
opinion in the US as well somehow we do
something from a u.s. perspective it
sends signals to the regional allies of
the u.s. we do not leave you alone it's
be Jordan beat Saudi Arabia beat Israel
and it sends a signal to the Assad
regime don't don't be too sure that we
do not get in engage militarily I mean
basically you're saying we've got troops
right on your back doorstep now so just
basically almost surrounded
by the US or by Western troops
absolutely if you take into
consideration the the Patriot missile
defense facilities and northern Turkey
you have you have Western troops already
in the north of Syria as well as in the
south asada it's basically the u.s. that
has been chiming in when we're talking
about any type of intervention we're not
hearing much from Europe I mean we did
have David Cameron coming in saying that
basically that Great Britain is behind
the White House on this but i mean i'll
bring you the other gentleman as well
basically europe is very quiet about
something that strategically is actually
much more important I mean Syria is
basically Europe's back door and you
could look at it that way why is why is
your being so silent now I mean the
first point is pretty obvious Europe is
simply divided on Syria one case or
particular cases the question of arms
embargo with regard to the Syrian rebels
and there's a huge disagreement among
Great Britain and France on the one side
and the basically the other European
powers on the other side if the arms
embargo should be extended at the end of
me but in general the european common
and foreign and security policy does not
play any major role in this syria case
and this is a huge dick disgrace for
europe and after after having pretended
for 20 years now that we are major play
in the european a board and the middle
east is part of the European able but
also I think you should notice that we
talk about intervention and in the
United States there's a lot of talk of
intervention but nobody really knows
what an intervention would look like
that would really stop the use of
chemical weapons or that would make this
terrible situation any better mean there
are possibilities I mean some people
talked about a no-fly zone for example
over Syria but not i'll bring you when
you you know you're in the business of
doing documentaries you've been in
countries where people suffer at the
hands of what the state is doing for
example we see that going on now we've
been seeing that now for two years in
syria and yet from al
side nothing basically is happening see
you you kind of see you kind of see
Europe and even the Americans why
they're a bit reluctant to go in I think
they if you look at recently where they
where they've been there's no there's no
case where they've actually gone in and
they've improved they've improved the
situation so I you can you can
understand their reluctance and so I
think I personally think as well that I
think the evidence really isn't there
right right now for them to for them for
them to go and I don't think and I don't
I can't see that happening either I
can't see them going in in in a rush
John McCain might he can say whatever he
wants but I can't see I really can't see
that I mean I know when I talk to people
in in Washington they all say you know
the Obama is terrified now of becoming
the next george w bush which is why he
is a fetishist for the truth in this
case Mr Kim you've said that the
appropriate time to act militarily would
have been a year ago why I think one
year ago the scenario wouldn't the Syria
scenario wouldn't have looked like Iran
Iraq sorry or Afghanistan but would have
or could have looked like for example
like Libya or even your even better
comparison the Balkans in the 1990s in
which it's rather small scale military
engagement i'm not talking about
invasion Year Engagement airstrikes
no-fly zone could have been very
effective without a political purpose or
with a clear political goal but simply
with the goal of n for slaughtering like
in the cause of all in 1999 but i think
this this point is has been order the
point of no return has been why would a
no-fly zone not help now because
obviously the rebels they can't compete
with the Assad regime's military when it
when it comes to air capability and that
superiority would be stopped if you had
a no-fly zone yeah one year ago you had
a very clear cuts division in the lab
rather clear cut on the one hand the
rebels or the opposition on the one hand
the Assad regime and now in the one has
happened there in the in the last year
is that the that the opposition has been
has been become way more blurred the
Islamists have have entered the country
the Islamist rebels the international
jihadists have entered the country
everything yeah have taken sides
Hezbollah as well so it has become more
internationalized than one year ago and
that has led to a situation in which
conflict maybe not resolution but
conflict management has become way more
difficult than one year ago you've also
said that everyone outside of Syria has
it has been diligent mised through all
of this waiting Russia China of course
at the UN Security Council they're not
going to vote for anything to happen the
rest of the members of the UN Security
Council in the u.s. there d legitimized
partly because of this language this red
line language which it seems like the
rhetoric is there but the action will
never come so what is going to happen
then mr. Khan I mean what do you see in
the crystal ball I mean most people say
that if nothing happens you're going to
have a civil war that's going to go on
for years and I mean we don't even want
to predict how many more people will
have to die I think the the skeptics
towards a military and intervention or
military engagement I on sofa right and
when they point to the question the the
unintended consequences you'll never
know who you're really arming but in a
mid and long-term perspective we're
facing even more unintended consequences
if Syria are not as a territorial entity
but as a political entity that will
simply dissolve wolf will fall apart
with consequences I know III do not even
dare to think about and with maybe even
destabilizing effects on other countries
in the region and that would really
affect the interests of all
international parties involved yeah I
mean I think the first time when we
talked on this show about the situation
in Syria most people were thinking in a
year or so we would be talking about
action haven't already been taken of
course now for two years into it and
nothing has happened yet so I'm sure
we'll be talking about this again
some point in the not too distant future
all right let's move on it is an
unprecedented tragedy in Bangladesh
around 400 people died when a garment
factory collapsed last week and that
number is expected to rise more bodies
will probably be discovered as heavy
equipment moves in to remove the rubble
the UK retailer Primark and the Canadian
retailer Loblaws have both announced
that they will pay compensation to the
survivors of the victims and also to the
victims relatives but they are not
taking responsibility for the disaster
in fact no one is standing up and saying
the protection of the workers lies with
me the owner of the factory even tried
to flee the country it was the worst
disaster ever to hit bangladesh's
garment industry for days firefighters
comb the rubble for survivors many using
their bare hands emergency workers tried
to pull people from the ruins rescuers
have now all but given up hope of
finding anyone else alive over 380 have
been killed and hundreds are still
unaccounted for a day before the
collapse workers felt a jolt and
discovered cracks appearing in the
structure several businesses in the same
building evacuated but the garment
factories on the upper floors told their
employees it was safe to go in police
have arrested six people in connection
with the collapse the owner of the
building was apprehended trying to flee
to India he had planning permission for
a five-story building but added an extra
three floors illegally
anger is growing over conditions for
Bangladesh's three and a half million
garment workers people here say it's
time to increase safety standards and
hold those in charge accountable anon
majha let me bring you in to talk about
this who needs to come up and say we are
responsible for what happened I think
definitely the owner of the factory is
one of the biggest culprits here I'd say
the government mr. nice it really needs
to look at themselves you know you
talked over there just on the three
extra floors were made but why were
three extra floors made how come that
was in checked on you know how can you
just make three extra floors and then
nobody comes and says well hold on those
three extra floors well how can you do
that I mean you bet you bill different
your inspections for four stars but but
I don't know if you know you may know
this that these this this guy who owned
the Rana factory he was totally in
cahoots with the government you know and
whether it be the Awami League which is
the current pie or whether it be the BNP
which is the previous party you know he
plays with both of them and that's not
just well what do you mean when you say
he plays with both of them is he a
contributor to the parties or did this
is what I mean yeah well because they
need to be in Coos to be able to get
there to be able to get the permits to
be able to make these factories he
doesn't just own that factory he's got
quite quite a few more you know a few
months ago he'd may he made some more as
well so you know what now what the
government really needs to be doing is
looking at those factories as well I was
just talking to you one of my one of my
friends who's who featured in the film
that we did about the garment workers
and she was telling me the factory that
she's working in has got cracks as well
you know the buildings are the same you
know and I just just just before we
started shooting here I was talking to
one of the other garment workers who was
in the film and they think that they're
saying the same so you can see the
pattern there and then just just last
year there was a factory 512 12 people
died it was at a scene factory fire and
you know they were producing clothes for
Walmart and primark but really they were
producing clothes for warmer just a few
months previous to that another factory
fire and not even that long before that
so that you can see the pan you know
nothing nothing you know no one is
been prosecuted for that no one is get
no one is getting no one is getting
prosecuted for that because it's that
industry makes so much money for the
country that they don't want no they
don't want to rock the boat if you know
what I mean we're going to we're going
to talk about the power of the industry
in just a moment but we've got a clip of
your film the machines that we want to
show and here you show an attempt to the
workers trying to organize to protect
themselves and show you that clip come
on you gotta you say what the butter
Monica she's had a family for hydrangeas
by the looks of Tarsus Bangladeshis
total darkness Monica said that if she
had the frozen assets
we on mr. Gargash today that should be
there and you know there we see workers
we were organizing they want to take
action against their bosses basically
but we also have to mention in
Bangladesh there are unions in the
garment industry why aren't they doing
anything they are they are the unions
are very much doing something that
they're got there getting people
together they're doing protest movements
you know just this weekend I'll give you
an example after after after this
tragedy the government give the workers
the weekend off so they didn't do you
know they didn't go to work in the
factories of the weekend and then they
were supposed to go back to work on
Monday but they all went back to work
and walk straight back out in protest
and why because they want something done
with that because of what's happened
with this new building with this
rebuilding and you said you talked to
people over there and they've told you
that in their factories they see also
cracks in the walls and is anything
happening are they still being well no
you have to work well that's it about
you know with this the Rana factory just
the day before that building was
evacuated and then the following day the
factory owners they they they force the
workers to come back in this is either
you come back in or your wages are going
to get docked and so they came back in
and you know when they when they when
they scare them like that one they'll
say your wages are gonna get docked you
know they're on a very small wage there
are about three 3000-4000 worst it's
where's the union then when that type of
ultimatum is given to workers isn't that
when a trade union is supposed to step
in and say wait a minute you can't do
that yeah well I think with it being so
quick the the Union probably weren't
able to do anything what they were able
to do is they were able to gather gather
the people together on the weekend
that's what you find in Bangladesh is
that it's only on the weekend is when
you see all the protest movements and
things like this happening very much
like in Europe as well you know you
don't see people protesting through the
week they'll always protest at the
weekend because they have jobs and
things like that to go to so you know
it's the same it's the same thing in
Bangladesh but the other thing to keep
in mind with the unions
is that you know these workers are very
brave to be members of the unions
because why is that because you're if
when you when you start becoming a
member of the Union you these young
girls they start getting intimidated you
know this is one of the things that we
talked about in the film and the girls
talk by themselves they get intimidating
for being members of the Union by by
whom by Bono yeah by the boss is Mike
the fact by the factory owners so you
know they're taking a huge risk to do
that but you seeing more and more people
becoming members because they realize
that they need they need to have their
eyes protector you told me before the
show that you are definitely not for a
boycott of garments coming from
Bangladesh because there has been talk
about what should the consumer be doing
in this situation and why is that
because obviously a boycott would would
hit the industry and its pocketbook yeah
I think the thing is we we work a lot
with the National workers ng W F which
is the national garment workers
federation and the leader of that is I'm
know how come in and another
organization we work with is called war
on one and they were we very much agree
that a boycott isn't it isn't isn't
what's needed because it's more there
needs to be changes within the window
within the industry you know there needs
to be agreements within the factories
fire and building safety agreements
things like this not a boycott of the
fear is is that if they start boy crying
they it could be a case that these
factories would these these brands
they'll just leave they'll just leave
the country go somewhere else and then
just start making the clothing over
there see the positive thing about the
garments industry that industry that is
bringing a huge amount of finances into
Bangladesh but what I think is the
biggest positive thing is is that it's
actually the garments industry employs
female workers and now these females if
they weren't working in these factories
more than likely because they're from
villages they would have got married at
a very young age they would have become
housewife so you're seeing p you're
seeing positive social change industry
empowering these women but on the other
hand because in the one hand is
empowering them but in the other hand
they're getting used and abused as well
by the factories what about the prime
minister of Bangladesh I mean she's a
woman yeah
why isn't she coming up to the plate and
and speaking out for women most of the
employees in these factories are women
like yeah I don't know if you've noticed
with this Rana factory think she was
very reluctant at first and then she has
she has because of public pressure she's
come forward now I'm he was criticized
because she waited a day before she said
anything yeah yeah she did but she
probably hoped that maybe it would just
you know I don't think maybe she thought
that ok there won't be that many people
dying right why just because last year
remember there was a fire as well you
know these things you know they'll get
forgotten within a few days but and it's
that's the case that is the case outside
of Bangladesh I know for a lot of people
i mean the consumer is always you know
we hear these appeals to the consumers
but let me ask you gentlemen do you
think when you buy a shirt do you
actually think about where it comes from
or the working condition at that moment
no i think of it now i ask myself what
what kind of responsibility do we have
here do we share a part of it
responsibility or guilt or whatever is
there anything we can do as a consumer
and and is it fair even to expect the
consumer to think about these things no
I just wanted to re-emphasize and
support your first point which I would
have found crucial that that regardless
of the of the behavior of the
International consumers i think it's
it's also the responsibility of the
Bangladesh government so it's a question
of bad governance I mean it's a fool
would have proper building laws and not
only existing but also being implemented
regulations regarding a safe working
environment we would have probably seen
a totally different outcome of the of
this in error